it just seems like nobody I mean it's
like World War one right everybody's in
their trenches throwing hand grenades
each other nobody's in the middle ground
nobody's even trying to get up and go
into the middle around and so nobody's
having those conversations like you said
where they they even make a lame attempt
to try to understand what the other
perspective might be yeah and in
particular it's exhausting in the sense
that not everything that this
administration again you know the caveat
be I didn't vote for Trump by hey I
didn't vote for Clinton you know we got
three hundred and what twenty million
people in this country you think we
could have come up with two other
candidates yeah but who did you vote for
you know what I just sounds really lame
but I just sat it out I couldn't get
myself to go vote for I just thought I
mean I was gonna vote for Ronald
Reagan's ashes or something but I you
know that I defecate I'd be the only
person so I didn't I didn't vote I
couldn't I couldn't figure out how we
got to that point hmm
and yeah the one person who should
really be pissed off was Bernie Sanders
I mean the only collusion we've really
proven up to this point yeah isn't the
ID seat colluding to keep Bernie down
and people sweep that under the rug so
quick it's so adorable it's adorable how
people just make it like that's not a
big deal but the deleting of 30,000
emails not a big deal collusion with the
DNC to rig the primaries not a big deal
yeah and Bernie got blessing me played
the good soldier and you know fell on
the sword and has it really well he
hasn't made much of an issue of it I
think it's because he has aspirations to
move forward and he knows they owe him
one now and he knows that Hillary
Clinton is essentially done that's
interesting well if they try to bring
her back in 2020 people go [ __ ] crazy
she might actually be thinking that well
I'm sure she what yeah they probably got
on a vitamin IV drip right now and
giving her hormone replacement therapy
and I decided to do yoga i I don't think
she'll I don't I just don't see her
being resurrected but maybe I'll try
maybe so I do think Joe Biden is coming
in you think so yeah I think he's
viewing this I think he's very upset
with others but I think he he probably
thinks at this stage of the game times
definite was tough guarding his family
but I think he probably regrets not
going in the last time hmm and I think
we're gonna see him throw his hat in the
ring because he's gonna look around he's
gonna think what am i up against I'm up
against Harris and Booker and you know
who else I mean I think he's got some
baggage though
oh forget about when I was in Boston we
used to have Joe Biden night at stitches
comedy club where we would plagiarize
each other's jokes Joe Biden people
don't remember this but in the 1980s he
got busted plagiarizing Kennedy's
speeches yeah people forgot about that
he ran for president in 88 yeah yeah and
that's a good point yeah you know me
everybody loves the guy that's sitting
on the bench right yeah so there were a
lot of Democrats I think after the fact
that they go I got if Joe had just run
but he's run a couple of times hasn't
worked out yeah and chewed him up yeah
yeah it would have been true so I you
know anyway but what I it's it's the
politics of it all are fascinating but
did you see the crazy [ __ ] when Trump
was saying he'd beat him up he's like
crazy Joe Biden so that he could beat me
out and beat me up yeah he would go down
fast and hard think they should have
just gone with that I think they should
have done some sort of celebrity match
that's when I was young I was saying
like let me let me be the commentator
can you see what that I mean the
president definitely does that both of
them would die yeah oh no no they did
get in the cage and it would be all over
I'm thinking five minutes a hair pull
Amy yeah pull whatever little hair they
have left the old schools the old school
wrestling Trump yeah sure thing with the
boots oh we got to get this going
yeah anyway he's just so ridiculous to
see Trump tweeting then he would beat up
Joe Biden if they ever fought yeah like
when who the [ __ ] have you ever fought
ever if you were you thrown a punch I
did this is the world we live in I mean
if I mean you think about all that you
think you think about the things we
should be talking about on a daily basis
right right and yet because of the
self-inflicted wounds that they
constantly have coming out of that White
House because of his tweeting for the
most part people aren't focusing on you
know think look we should all be able to
agree Democrats and Republicans should
be
agree that yeah if you can get your way
to peace on the Korean Peninsula that's
pretty damn good
yes